here what is wrong with my
windows all right um I've been out for a
few days because I've been doing a lot
of Dev on stream to the point there was
so much Dev I just needed to focus in on
stuff for a few days and there's still
quite a bit left to do but it's in a
little bit of a better place now um at
least it was until this new project
randomly cropped up
um so let me talk a little bit about
what's going on here CU there's there's
something pretty cool that we're
starting on and it'll be easier if I can
just show the
code all right puffer
lib
puffer and
TCG oops I got to pull this
TR right
so what we have here is a very
early not even working prototype I had a
a somewhat working prototype before but
I have to refactor it keep up the work
thank you thank you I'll say so what
we're doing today
here um I I figured that I had a little
bit of something I could stream uh
there's still a lot of stuff I got to
finish off stream this the next update
to puffer is literally 10,000 lines of C
it's it's going to Triple the size of
the library and puffer is going to go
from 98% python to like 60 70% c
repo where is this
perer lib
environments
okay do see
so what happened here is I had all these
environments that I was working on right
and they were in kind of a good spot and
I was kind of ready to lock this set of
environments in for the next update uh
but then randomly we had like five
different people get interested in
building a trading card game environment
for puffer uh and generally when you get
people interested in doing stuff right
you have to have something that they can
work on very quickly before they get
distracted and you lose momentum so what
I've been doing over the last couple of
days
is I've been working on this little
prototype it's based Loosely off of uh
Magic the Gathering um if we get sued
it'll be based off of a different card
game right uh it doesn't really matter
like it's for AI to play anyways but the
idea is just to have some sort of TCG
environment for RL that has a lot of the
complexity in it and we have
contributors interested in this we've
got one formal uh research collab with
another lab we've got a guy that's been
already contributing a bunch of M who's
interested in this and we've got a
couple others as well now so people want
to do this and really the thing that I
want to get
today I want to ship a working minimal
prototype that feels fine to play that
has just the basic elements of a game so
not all the triggers not all of like the
fancy card effects and stuff but just
like you can play a land I guess a Mana
card whatever you can play your cards
you can attack you can block that type
of stuff uh I think that that whole
thing is doable in about 500 lines of
code and I got very very close to doing
that um but the way that I built it it
the code was just getting too
complicated and had too much branching
for people to be able to use it so I
came up with a weird idea on how to make
it better and uh that's what we're going
to be doing right
now welcome back sorry was traveling to
Costa Rica but another the loop this
this is awesome to catch well I mean
I've been out for a few days as well
I've been I've been doing a combination
of Devon
meetings um you know puffer is a company
and we are starting to look for collabs
and clients and things so if you got
companies that want some help with RL
stuff you let me know but uh yeah it's
been there's been a bunch of meetings
and there's been a bunch of
Dev it's been productive but definitely
busy
so let's talk a little bit about what
I'm wanting to do here so we've got this
TCG environment thing uh you have a card
array that can be used to represent a
deck a hand the board whatever you've
got Health you've got Mana got whether
you've played a land this turn you've
got some data that tells you who's
attacking and who's
defending few other variables and then
the stuff you'd expect
here the thing that's tricky and also I
should move this
like this
yeah and you'll be able to see a little
bit you see how much branching there is
here and down here it's even uh it's
even worse so that's the
renderer I let me get an image of this
as well because this doesn't build right
now but I have on the Discord I posted
in the puffer Discord so you can get us
just a sense of what this thing looks
like it's very very basic
oh wow this guy's made his uh his go
environment awesome we got all these
contributors making cool
stuff hey folks you guys can hop in and
just like build stuff if you want like a
lot of these people have no prior RL
experience it's really just if you can
code like if you can code you can make
these
environments cuz puffer handles a lot of
the infra stuff for you let me see if I
can find the TCG screenshot that I
dropped in Dev here
before this it maybe I put it in
gen okay yeah here's the TCG prototype
so you've got cards they've got stats
they've got lands you can play them to
the board right and then you can attack
and block and stuff uh so we want this
working today cleanly in a way that just
feels reasonable to play and you feel
like you you could play something with
it cool CAU never caught your stream
live before love the project thank you
yeah I haven't been streaming the last
few days cuz like the dev has kind of
been a bit much and also there's one
there's one new environment that is not
announced yet that will be open source
but I want it to be done and sort of
like release it all at once uh that's
going to be like a 4,000 line commit on
its own so there a lot of code and also
just too many damn
meetings but hey come got to get Revenue
right and also I mean there are a lot of
cool people doing stuff with ourl that's
fun to talk to but so much def needs to
get
day yeah you can see what a mess this is
right like this is in a while loop and
like there all these phases and you can
see all this branching stuff and you can
see all these print statements with me
trying to debug this mess um is this the
Moa M oh no this is a new one uh the Moa
is still that's still around we're still
going to work on this this is just the
skeletal prototype of a TCG trading card
game uh this is what it looked like
before I broke stuff we want to get it
back to looking like this maybe with a
couple extra things and we want it to be
like nice clean code that people can
build off of because I think this one is
going to be largely Community
Development Le like we have enough
contributors that want to work on this
project that if I get them a skeleton of
it like a prototype they'll be able to
take it from there with my input but I
really need to get a clean starter code
for them pretty much so that's what
we're doing today uh I'm going to open
up I'm going to open up like a draw tool
because one of the reasons I jumped on
stream is because I wanted to just talk
through my thoughts on how to design
this cuz I got a little stuck
yesterday and I I know usually I can
figure stuff out if I just spend some
time talk through it on
stream not this
one yeah this
okay
so with the TCG
right you've got
like the key
elements excal draw is that
better
cool uh hold Mouse wheel
or space bar while
dragging
um so with the TCG you have like your
deck that you draw from right you've got
your
[Music]
hand you've got your board State it's
like maybe something like this which is
your board the opponent's board they've
got their
[Music]
hand their deck and then there's also
like graveyard or whatever
right and the key thing here is that
there are a ton of phases and there's
like branching logic and you need to
figure out when you actually want to
return it to the user it's the tricky
part cuz like so you there's like draw
right
and then once you draw okay this is
actually kind of nice that the way this
feels this is funny um so you have draw
phase and then
like so once you draw right you have to
be able to play your cards right so then
there's like a play
Phase then there's like attack
TCG is a trading card game so magic the
Gathering Hearthstone Legends of Runa
one of
those the thing that's really tricky
with these phases is that um they're
kind of
conditional so
like let's say that you draw your card
right but then there aren't any cards
cards that you can play then what you
want to do is you want to skip
potentially straight to the attack phase
and if there is nothing that you can
attack with then you skip you know over
like this but if there's a card that you
can play right but you can't attack then
maybe you skip down like this so it's
like this chain of events is kind of
weird and it's very difficult to express
this uh in typical branching logic so
what I was going to do is I was going to
have there be an explicit call stack oh
and by the way there are a lot of things
that do this because later on when we
start implementing cards like there are
cards that will add essentially
stages into this stack of of things as
well so what I was thinking is we have
like this explicit call
stack right where we go
like uh
draw and then when this gets called you
know this is going to put onto the next
one this will put
play and then you draw so then you just
have
play and then if you actually need uh if
you can't attack or whatever like this
thing will check basically for what it
puts onto the call stack next
you and then if each of these functions
returns like a a code or something it
can tell us whether we're done right
now so basically we have these functions
they can get chained together in a nice
Loop and we will be able to tell when um
when we're ready to return control to
the user or not I think that this design
works I think that this is how you do a
so let's try this because this is what I
started implementing just very very
briefly
then okay I think I need to just like
move all these things into their own
attack uh these also need to know your
action I
believe yeah so let's do
this so each of these goes into their
own function
block and then I think we're going to
get a pretty
clean like main phase logic out of this
maybe
it's kind of hard to tell still whether
this will be the way to do
it this still feels very doable though
it's like maybe slightly more
complicated than I thought originally
but like really still not that
bad okay
so when you call step here
I think we don't do any of this pointer
Shenanigans and we just kind of write
yeah I do actually have to grab the
reset method from uh up
top because you'll see in a second reset
actually does have to call step the way
I'm doing it now
folks this is this is a project that
we're going to need contributors on as
well like as soon as I get this
prototype done hopefully today uh it's
going to basically be on the community
to like add stuff to
this the code will ideally be much
cleaner though before I hand that
over okay so here's the reset
uh we don't like this draw phase thing
here at all oh no this is fine this is
just drawing the initial
cards phase draw I don't think we even
need phase indicators anymore do
we I don't think
this we also probably should just make
some like
stack just we should make some stack
thing just explicitly just so I don't
mess it
up let's just do um
I don't know
stack where I put
call in
action PCG and int okay and then what
we'll do is type death
Dr
have this is just going to be
call uh data of Stack
size and then this is going to have
int uh
idx right and then we'll just do
void
back uh
push it's going to
be probably can just do like this push
back St stack and then it's going to
have
all
function
seert that we have room in the stack
index yeah that's easy right minus equal
one and then we return the thing from
the
stack and we actually don't even need to
delete stuff from the stack because we
just use the indices basically to keep
track of stuff so this is very
nice um very very basic probably don't
even need that uh I could do it manually
every time but like that's kind kind of
fine
right okay let's go to our
TCG and then we'll just do right here
this is going to be
stack
kind of
stack kind of nice now we go to our step
nice now we go to our step
function reset
base draw yeah so we push draw to the
stack and then we call a step on the
environment
then we can do uh all
function is going to be popped from the
stack
code
uh
return this is literally it this is
going to be the whole logic of the game
is it's just going to be doing stuff
like
this and then these function should be
able to just grab whatever the next
thing is and put them on the stack
I don't know if this design is actually
a good idea yet but uh I think this is
probably what we
want
yeah okay
so if we look at it this
way goes to BU
action so you return true is return to
user
just because this is going to I don't
even know if this is smart but I'm going
to do one thing real
quick I don't know if this is true I
mean I don't know if this is smart
but I think that this will prevent me
from doing dumb
things uh so this is going to
be return to
user so you see what I'm trying to do
here is I'm trying to set up like when
like all these functions that get called
in the stack some of them say Hey you
know you took an invalid action or you
know the user needs to make a decision
or whatever those are going to break the
whole call chain and get the next
action and wait for the user to like
click something or whatever or the agent
to make an action but some of them don't
some of them just want to grab the next
function okay so this is return to user
then this is
n or this is push
phase attack
right and then you return to the
this this is going to take quite a bit
of bidding though
and then what do we doing here okay this
is determining whether we can play any
cards right
and this is
tapping figuring out how many lands you
can
tap oh yeah and then we have this
absolutely gross thing here right
I think I'm going to do one another
thing here as
action we'll handle that later yeah
we'll handle that later so if you hit
I think we remove
this this is going to return to the
user this returns to the stack
and I don't know why we have this as
action enter
either yeah this untap step is in the
wrong spot anyways
this and we make uh an untap phase
explicitly right
this these are going to drive me
uh yeah these things are going going to
drive me nuts I got to figure out a way
around having to do
board D Mana
zero tap is false
right we do
push yeah it does okay so this is going
to be push
draw and then this is going to be return
to
stack hi sir wanted to learn
ml so there's no entry level
jobs data analyst need your
job yeah it's
not yeah there there's not I mean there
are no entry-level jobs in rocket
science either right and like yeah
applied ml's not exactly rocket science
science anymore it's a lot easier than
it used to be but you still need to
learn some things uh for sure so really
it depends on where you are right like
if you're in University and you're smart
studying things then yeah you can do
stuff in ml um it really depends on your
situation
some like applied AI team jobs are out
of undergrad a lot of them want like a
master's and then their research jobs
are generally
information yeah ml is going to get much
more on the technical side very quickly
um again like applied
stuff is not as much but like there's
still some level of mathematics um and
programming right some quite substantial
level of that
so I it's there's no prerequisite to
learn ml right so like I the the best
thing you can do is just like very
quickly start trying some up some stuff
out and seeing if you actually like
doing
it like you can very very quickly get a
sense for that that's I mean that's
probably the best recommendation I can
give
you like there's so much material out
there nowadays for just like getting a
sense of some stuff very quickly and see
if you actually like this stuff right
see like what TCG are you trying to
implement yeah it's something pretty
close to Magic Ramy
and I had a working prototype mostly
working but
um the structure of it just wasn't it
wasn't where it needed to be in order
for it to be you know reasonably
right well no you actually you need to
have this stuff inside of an explicit
Ken play check I
think yeah we're going to do it this way
for now
I really hate these types of functions
here I don't know maybe somebody will
come up with a way to
we don't need this
check so Ken play is
false we get the Min cost card we figure
out how much uh we can
tap and then we need to get
Mana so
return star Mana plus
tapable greater than equal Min cost so
this tells us whether there is a card
that we can
play and then what we'll
do is
if if you can't
play we'll just put no valid
moves valid
moves and then this is going to return
to the user and we're going to push
phase
sense why does this return to the user
and this returns to the
this yeah definitely if there are uh TCG
players who have a better understanding
of this than I do that would be great I
I have very little TCG experience just
in order to be able to build this over
the weekend I uh I downloaded like mtga
and got to Silver real quick with a
really meme mono red
done I mean it's like literally
impossible not to get to Silver because
they literally don't even like you don't
even lose rank for losing so it's just
like if you play games you will get to
Silver in like some number of
hours I'm surprised how active it is
though like you get 10 second Q times
action as ever
enter then you're going to
push phase
I think that actually all these are
going to push to the
stack yeah I think pretty much all of
these are just going to push to this
stack
what about actually playing the
card that's right here
hand
board probably
this I don't like these like these
header things up
top
um I I know how we're going to end up
getting rid of these but for now it's a
okay I kind of see how this works you
push so whenever the user does something
invalid you push the current phase back
onto the stack and you return to the
user right so this is if they try to
play a land and they've already played
one right you push you say nope we're
going to do the same thing again after
we return to the user
user okay and then you play this card
right so then this is going to be
push uh why is this not Auto completing
is my Wi-Fi dropping or something oh no
we're
good base Play
Return to user
then you need to know how many you can
tap right how many lands you can
and is this actually correct let me see
no you don't need this tapable
zero
what garbage
suggestions it's you want this thing
here okay
Mana B play and then return to
user and now here it's going to autotap
your lands for you
you're going to
board and then you just start tapping
stuff
right and you played your
card push F play and you return to the
user okay this is actually already
looking
better you have this very clean control
flow here
where each phase
essentially can either directly like add
to another phase and you don't have to
check too deep into it either right so
like you know let's say that there no
valid moves right so you go to the
attack phase but you don't know if there
any valid attacks so what it'll do is
it'll just push the attack phase on the
attack phase will determine whether or
not there are any valid attacks if there
no valid attacks it'll skip over the
block phase entirely and go back to draw
phase and you essentially you only ever
trigger back to the
user when there's actually something to
interact with so this is like a very
nice way of doing um control flow
without ending up with like deep
recursion or any like that or
really deep call
chains cuz essentially you just have
this explicit call
stack I like this this is a much better
design at least so far it looks like
this is a much better
design so like right here for
instance this for MTG
yeah well we can't call it mtj that
name's kind of Taken can we call it puff
for this scho
or something like
that okay so like if you can't attack
right you're going to just push on uh
this is the draw phase
right
turn you give it the draw
phase just go like this then you return
you return to stack
and then if you ever if you hit
enter your attacks get
confirmed and actually none of this is
needed here
right attacks confirmed phase end you
push phase
block
and you return to the
stack and then this stuff is actually
going to go into the user uh this will
all go into the block code now so this
is so much
cleaner this is kind of a weird pattern
I've not really had to implement
anything that has uh a comparable
pattern to this
before it's very nice
it avoids these very deep call chains
doesn't need
recursion kind of explicit recursion I
guess so phase attack if you can't
attack you skip the
phase you actually skip over
phases if action is
enter then you go to the block phase
right
um and if your action is invalid
essentially so you go back to your
attack phase and then you return to
here this is actually a valid
one you push the attack phase and go
back to the user
this these prints are giving me
agida I just want these okay so we can
see that it's actually pretty simple
oh actually I get it so what I was doing
here so this is just going to skip stuff
that you don't need to block
right and if you get to
here nothing left to block
end I don't like this
no I don't like
weirdness oh hold
on I don't have to worry about the block
phase if there's no attack phase with
this design that never
happens so I can actually just delete
this
great and uh now this is going to be
well we have to figure out what to do
with this code let's just move this down
for
now I think this is actually the same as
right here isn't it do I even need this
piece of code for anything
can block not can block literally this
gets deleted yeah we don't need this
anymore the new design makes it
[Music]
irrelevant can things change in the
middle of phases because of instance yes
and this is one of the reasons I'm
designing it this way by having an
explicit call stack um basically when I
want to add in instance what I'm going
to be able to do is like anytime there's
an interrupt I'm just going to be able
to check like you know instant response
or whatever and if there is one I can
just push it back on the call stack you
see it's going to be kind of cool like
that so right now even though it's a
stack it doesn't ever become a deep
stack right CU there's always just going
to be one thing on the stack it's just
like this phase to this phase to this
phase to this phase but when I want to
add instance what's going to happen is
like uhoh there's a chance that you can
have an instant here so you know you put
the Instant on the stack and then the
instant resolves it gets taken off the
stack and you go right back to where you
were and that all happens nice and
cleanly this is the reason that I'm
doing it myself right for the Prototype
is so that when I hand this to the
contributors right when I hand this to
the rest of everybody there will at
least be like this nice structure in
place that's had some thought put into
it
let me see how I want to handle this
little portion here
enter this is the one that's a little
tricky getting this blocking stuff right
cuz you have to be able to choose block
um like which cards block what and
stuff let me think a moment here so the
tricky thing
what I essentially want to do which I
guess I'll just do explicitly for now
is I want to like copy
this
again I want to put this
here so we'll figure something out how
to clean this or or whatever
this yeah no I should not need to do
this no I'm thinking about this I'm
still thinking about this wrong
what this should
be is you advance the block
index
one and then you return you
push the block phase and you push back
to the stack I think
yes I just have to get the logic for
this
right okay
[Music]
action this is an invalid block so we
return to the
user and then what's this you can't
block with Y land yeah we push block and
return to
user Okay so
oh they're just doing some maintenance
outside okay
um so the tricky thing is basically just
figuring
out when to actually
trigger the blocking calculations
so you skip block you skip
Block it's going to return to the user
eventually we're going to assume that we
handle
this action
thing and
then I think it's just if the block
index
yeah there are a few edge
cases this is okay already
blocked so your action is invalid for
this is where you should resolve it it
should be at the top I think this is
where it gets
okay so now we're assuming that it's not
resolving
now so here this is already blocked so
this is push this and then return to
user and then this is okay we're
blocking right push block and return to
user uh and then this goes there and and
then this is good so now we just have to
check this Logic for actually resolving
the block calculations which should not
be that
bad let me go through this one more time
though so the logic here is that you
enter the block phase you skip over all
the cards that aren't attacking if
you're at the end of the board then
you're done uh you're done with all of
the block calculations so you resolve it
you resolve all the blocks otherwise
you see if the users hit enter if the
users hit enter you advance to the next
thing that needs to be blocked if their
action is invalid then you push back to
the user and say Hey you know pick
something valid uh if you're trying to
like this is also invalid action
handling right here if you're trying to
uh block use a card to block something
but you've already used that card to
block something
else and then if none of these things
are true then you toggle the block state
of your current card and you push this
um onto the will not call it the
blockchain but the block
I got to set up a couple more meetings
in Pao Alto while I'm still here for the
next couple weeks so I got to give some
of these guys
out we got
them are you building the TCG for fun
well it's another RL environment
right it's going to be another RL
environment to add to the
collection it's got some interesting
properties to it it's a good environment
for research and for testing algorithms
right it's mainly because uh people were
interested in contributing to it so I
figure okay I can get a nice little
prototype of this set up and then you
know if contributors are going to want
to actually do a bunch of stuff on this
then
great not attacking not attacking
uh I think that this is actually all
correct right down until
here which is
push we have to push
phase uh draw onto the
stack and then we have to
stack skeleton for others sounds good
yeah what properties does it have the
other like poker don't I mean play MTG
and then play poker
right must
zero
oh yeah I really don't like this
um I
don't look I've it's only been a few
months since I've been doing stuff in C
like a couple months even probably only
been like one month really since I've do
it been doing stuff in proper C in the
last 10 years there's still a few things
I'm getting used to and this is like a
really big foot gun which is if you if
you callic something right then it gets
zeroed for you but if you allocate it
not on the stack it doesn't get zeroed
for you
um so I don't know if you're just
expected to zero your Stacks or if I'm
supposed to have if the init method is
supposed to do it for you um
that's just like a potential way to
screw stuff up those for getting to zero
it this looks good though I think we are
almost at the point where we can start
testing
this function you don't need these
anymore
and I think once we cut some stuff out
it'll be about 500 lines maybe 600 I did
say 600 initially for the Prototype so
that might have been
prophetic but let's look at the logic
for
this because I think this will be pretty
clean so you go to reset you push a draw
phase and you call
step well in the draw
phase phase
draw do I not have a phase draw
function I guess I don't have a phase
draw function that would be bad
base
draw and then what we're going to do
is uh card array
hand card array Our
Deck draw card deck
hand do not
push push phase phase play
and then you return to this
stack so now you call phase draw it
draws a card and it pushes phase play to
the
stack next thing uh on the stack gets
pulled or popped I
mean see you good luck thank
how Okay the one thing I don't like
about this is how the actions Cascade
through right cuz like I'm essentially
I'm just calling phase play to see if
you can even play at
all right
I think you kind of just want to no op
right let me think if that makes
sense I think you need to add an action
no
like the stack is always going to return
right until the point that you need the
action right
so here you step with a no
op and I think what you do
user action equals no op you only ever
use the first action
let me see how I like
full and then we do if action is a no
op we return to the
user so essentially we just get these
these two initial checks
off we'll have to do
some some stuff maybe to speed this up
but I think for now this is
fine cuz there's a little bit of
redundant checking
here then if they hand hand length to
Big okay we've done all this
now action enter returns
to uh action
enter returns to the
play and this actually is going to
return to
the the stack as well
right
yeah uh if you can't play Then you
return to the user lens get Auto
tapped base play this is also to this
Phase or is this to the wait is this to
the user the stack hold
user yeah this is to user I was right
right yeah it's not until enter okay so
we do this then we go to phase
attack
um if you can if you cannot
attack then you go to the draw
user if enter
okay and then phase block is going to be
very similar
right we return to the user
is how do we know if there's nothing to
block
check hold on how do we know if there's
nothing to block
with I mean I maybe I at this point I
just start debugging live
gross I have a weird dependency order
thing don't
I I think I need to do what I need to do
is I need to move the type def for the
TCG
up so that they know that there's going
to be the compiler needs to know that
there is a
TCG TCG struct up here
okay that could s all the way down to
63 get the
board unused variable hand yeah we don't
need hand we just need the board
here uh can play not used
true unused board
W
these I think you actually need to Ford
declare these don't
you yeah you actually need to for
declare these because they all call each
other
incompatible yeah this is going to be
stack star
array so when we do allocate we need to
do n stack is going to be there's no
allocate stack so this is a
calices a
stack holy
right yeah it's like this it's a type
def bull
there we
go conflicting type definitions for
phase
attack I guess technically
uh it should
maybe conflicting types for
phase untap going to be sign
Char conflicting
type this is a
well Undeclared identifier board this is
fine heart
oops
health I guess this needs a few
different things huh in Star
well non-void
function does not
return well I don't know what happened
here there we go
builds okay so here is is the
TCG we're now going to have to debug
played card is
played
enter I really need to have this phase
indicator
I need the phase indicator back I forgot
that I need it just to draw what phase
it is if nothing
call function is going to be
Peak and then what we're going to do is
IF function is going to be equal to
phase draw then you draw the
text what we think about this so I just
do it based on literally what's on the
stack and instead of having to maintain
a separate
State base
play already played land
okay that's a legit bug let's fix
that yeah this is going to be so much
better
though okay this just has to
go this just just has to go up to here
else
if else
if
land Attack
so setting attacker one setting attacker
two actions confirmed phase
end invalid Block action 11 that's
another legitimate
bug this already feels so much better
though
great rectangle of zero got summoned
yeah it's debug stuff right it's pretty
important to have this honestly I'm
probably going to make like a debug
print or something so I can leave these
prints in the code and just have it with
a debug flag or something
because I don't know how else you debug
a TCG like this you really need to know
you need to know a lot about the
underlying game
State they just like compared to almost
any other game there just so many
interactions that can happen once this
thing gets
going the goal of this is to show
um the goal is to show like what you're
blocking with what card right so like
the row is the
attackers it's well the row is going to
be the attackers and then the Call's
going to be Defenders so if I put one
here it's like you're blocking uh the
fourth attacker with your first card or
something like that you're blocking
their fourth card with your first
card yes so if action is a no op and you
go back to the
this player land Player Two Cards hit
enter attack with these two
phase zero action
11 skipping block for zero not
attacking okay so it's letting me try to
block stuff is the problem right
now so it's not detecting that there's
no valid Block
it's not detecting that there's no valid
Block action
correct let me see where I'm supposed to
be handling
this well I'm just not handling it
anywhere
cookie
[Music]
somebody made some like really dumb
tweet about like the Energy Efficiency
of programming
languages and I I replied to it like
well I eat three chocolate chip cookies
debugging C so how's that count for
energy here to learn a bit yeah of
course
mean I've been coding seriously for what
like at least 12 13 years
now the cool thing about what I'm doing
at the moment though is like you really
don't need to know too much of the
context for all the reinforcement
learning stuff that I have right in
order to do this type of stuff like
we have people that are just competent
developers um that are making new
environments for puffer like really
useful stuff for reinforcement learning
in the day from scratch um so that's
pretty cool right like that's not a
thing that you used to be able to
do so you know it can't we can't make it
to the point where like anybody could do
it but we can make it you can bring the
bar down a lot
much more
accessible and the C is not required
either like you can write these things
in scyon they just won't render on the
web as all
um and for scientists that's
fine one of the nice things about C is
it's like it's not not hard but it looks
hard
so it kind of weeds out the people that
actually don't care and don't actually
want to learn
stuff like I don't have to gate peep
people I do the exact opposite like
people just gep themselves
instead which is kind of fun
it's actually very nice and comfortable
writing this stuff and
see I think it would be like at most
marginally easier in
fast what's your number one go-to
resource I haven't written C in 10 years
like literally I barely use C outside of
uh university
courses um it's just like when you've
been developing for like 10 plus years
and you at least have some understanding
of what low levels are supposed to be
right like I had courses and whatever uh
it's just not that hard it's all it is
like I haven't done anything specific I
just started using it that's
all I mean they're like at most there
are a couple like weird syntax
differences and yeah you need to
understand pointers that's about
it but it's like whoop did you do a
pointer stores the address of a variable
instead of having the value itself
that's it that's that's all it is
the only thing I will say that you do
need to know
exists somebody does have to tell you
that these flags exist if you do not
know that these flags exist for
compiling you will have a very bad time
because you will not get good error
messages
um but it's not that bad
otherwise let me figure out where this
error
is by any chance of you seeing the uh
the Pokemon Red work cuz I see your
username um have you seen like the
Pokemon Red reinforcement learning stuff
cuz that's another I mean that's
probably the biggest project that puffer
is sponsoring at the
I need some way of just checking if
there's nothing left to block
with
right yeah I think I just have to copy
this it's going to be slightly different
code saw on some social media or YouTube
well there's some cool results coming
out with that soon uh you can you can
try the Discord for that I mean that
that project has actively been under
development like I think it was in
January or whatever like it's been under
development the whole time
it's the main thing that puffer sponsors
we uh most of the puffer cluster compute
goes to that
I this is where it needs to happen right
here
right just joined solid there's also
discord.gg SLP puffer which is our
Discord that's where we do all the uh I
mean there's all sorts of cool stuff in
here like I have this environment we've
got like all sorts of other people
posting environments and stuff
I think somebody just made go like a go
environment here's somebody making
Enduro from scratch Ultra
hyperf here's new car
environments got go all this stuff
speaking of which there's one of the new
contributors the guy that just did go
I've got to give him access to the
cluster people that uh contribute stuff
consistently get cluster
access Discord it's literally
discord.gg SLP
Puffer for
block
equals false
go well I just need to see if there's
anything on the
board uh that can block
if
en Defenders
I don't like the way that this is
looking but let me see
is
land then you
land and then you have to look here I'm
essentially just trying to figure out if
you have any cards available to block
attacker block index a PL attacker J
with card I I believe
block with card is false
M Stack yes it holds the current the way
it works is like each phase is a
function um that has access to the full
game
State and whatever is on the top of the
stack is the current phase
let me do if can
block uh then you
break and then if not can
block nothing left to block
with well you need to trigger the
resolve right
simplify okay so what does this
say skipping block for not attacking
so can block with
one well it definitely can't block with
one
wrong am I even doing this reasonably
like
goes this goes over the length of the
board of my board right yeah
oh wait no it's got to be the defender
board
EnV and so EnV is the environment that
is the full game State opponent op is
just for
opponent oh look at that that actually
worked
uh I don't know why this guy didn't
play a
land and we do we're going to play our
land for this turn up already played
land this turn definitely did not so we
got to do the untap step correctly
time for
cookie one cookie per day
limit probably could use a second cookie
per day but one cookie per day
limit honestly it's not that bad that I
have the bakery nearby you should have
seen when I was in Boston there were no
like bakeries close by there was just
Dunkin
Donuts I think I was having between 25
and 30 Donuts
let me think is that right maybe between
20 and 30 Donuts per week it was like
three or four Donuts a day it was
ridiculous
for how
long good few months how are you not
super obese cuz IID start my day with
like an hour and a half or two hour run
and then I would lift in the
evening you just burn
I was running like 40 miles a week
then I'm probably I'm only doing like 25
30 miles a week at the moment because
I'm doing more strength work but
um yeah mileage varies depending on
training you got to do reinforcement
learning on yourself to do reinforcement
learning on the agents you know that
works
uh I think what's Happening Here
is
Phase yeah this has got to go to phase
untap
right reset goes to phase
draw phase untap goes to draw
well now I think we're
good
so we play our
land we play our
on let me figure out where this is
getting messed
with phase
attack this is going to go to phase
untap
phase
uh cool I think that does
it so we play
land then we play these
we do two damage it's a lot of damage we
get our
land now we have two lands so we can
play
this ah it let us play both of them
which is not
good now our
attack we can attack with all
this and they actually play
something let's fix our lands per turn
thing real quick though
see if I just do like
three two five say already played land
this turn
right
okay and then
three three already played land this
turn
oh no it didn't it that's the thing it
it's not that it's the Mana on
car you autotap your lands
right assert the Mana is less than the
card
cost okay star Mana minus equal card
cost right
build I think this is good
now
three I can't play these and play
these we
attack can't play the next Land good I
play
this aha not enough Mana very good can't
do anything so we just
swing this is going to inflict five
damage taking us down to 13
here we play our land brings us up to
three lands we cannot play this card not
play a second land we can play
this and then we
this and it says it can block now with
zero can block with
zero
right look at
that so I can choose to block right here
I can hit enter now I'm choosing I can
choose to block this one
right let's choose to block this one
like
destroyed it did but his land also got
destroyed so I don't know how that
happened well the line
yeah it's just showing what is targeting
what
um so then I should just win right let
me see if I play my next
land uh I play this big card I hit enter
I do
there's the full
board uh we
swing and now he's on negative health
block star Health negative equal to this
this then we do
if Health Less Than
over and then we simply
do
reset all right let's see what else is
wrong with this so we play our land we
play our
cards we swing we do
damage we try we can play this now
and then we
swing and we didn't get any chance to
block
right so
next we're going to play our
land play this
and we swing and now it's going to let
us select the block
here we're going to block here and what
we're expecting is for my uh zero Mana
one one to get destroyed their card to
get destroyed and the land to
remain yeah so that didn't happen uh
something completely screwy just
happened
you can see that this is correct though
so right
here this is it was blocking this
card with his first
card so this was correct and then
somehow the uh the resolution is wrong
where does reset come
from resets right
here it just resets the game
State and you can see that it um it
pushes the first thing onto the stack
which is how it starts it it pushes the
uh the draw phase onto the
stack there might be a a couple other
things that we have to reset but that's
the main
thing so let's see what this uh what
messages we have attacker board length
was seven resolving zero not attacking
yep resolving
land resolving
one attacker
wins oh I was yeah the implementation
has just gotten stale this is like an
auto block thing
yeah this is like an auto blocker thing
um I got to just re rethink about this
real
quick the team is going to be pretty
happy though to have this to work off of
when I get this ready because this is
not this is really not
bad it'll be under 600 lines I'll make
sure of that cuz I promised them like
600 lines was the Prototype that's what
I estimated that's what it
be okay so you're going through the
attacker so far so good
right you get their
attack Defender board length
if
not M
Defenders
attack
defense
continue have their
defense you have their card
wins well it's not really attacker wins
or Defender wins here right
hacker
attack let's
swing play this play this
[Music]
swing and then what we're going to
do is we're going to do
this it
worked it
worked you see
that our card was destroyed their card
was destroyed the rest of the combat
went
through so this is a mostly working
prototype
then why do you have attack or attack
and attack attack which you have
assigned so it's kind of messy at the
moment but the idea is I don't know if
you've played magic um when you attack
something um your attack gets temporary
decreased by uh so like let's say that
you have five attack okay and then you
attack something that has two health and
then you're also attacking something
that has like one Health what'll happen
is you hit the first one your attack
goes down to two now you have three
attack left you hit the second one I I
think I said it has two Health you have
three attack left uh you hit that now
you have one attack left and that one
extra damage goes to face so it goes to
the opponent
so but the thing is you're not actually
permanently reducing your attack you're
only reducing it for the purpose of that
one
computation yeah it's a temporary thing
exactly so I have to keep track of that
separately so what we're going to do now
I'm going to use the restroom real quick
quick I'll be right back and then we're
going to finish cleaning this up uh
you're going to see you know how I clean
all this up nicely we're going to clean
up all the logging and stuff we're going
to get it down to hopefully 600 lines
and then I'm going to ship this as a
prototype to the team and uh I think
people are going to be very excited we
might also do a little bit of stuff with
the rendering
differently I kind of should have a
separate zone for
lands I don't know how I'm going to deal
with that maybe I just won't bother for
now I also kind of want to render when
lands are tapped um but yeah I'll be
right
what team you're working
with uh open source team frankly
like puffer is a company but all the
contributions and stuff and all the code
are all open
source I think this is going to have to
be called puffer the schooling
better all right we have to clean this
up
needed put this here these are all
forward declarations these can all go
together we have our
stack how do people do code blocks and
see do they just like do this type of
stuff this is kind of gross
right yeah that's kind of
so we do Health
[Music]
I'm kind of like doing this
maybe organize these a little bit you
bottom lock index turn yeah this is okay
this is laid out kind of
fine
stack there that's nice and
condensed uh these allocate and freeze
are good
randomize
deck draw a
bit H they're kind of fine like
this can attack
Mana I don't like the way that we have
these question mark statements
here
um technically I could make pointers
that are like always updated to the
current
thing I don't know if that's worth
it I'm going to leave these alone for
now
was there like a standard cdbg print or
you just make your own
of why is it autocomplete to
rust get out of here rust
uh this is not going to let me do like
my Matrix and stuff is it
right I forgot about
that well I think we'll leave it for now
we'll just not do that for now we'll
just like clean up the prce and not do
any of that
untap can you get the name of a function
and see
now no there's not a like that's too
much we'll just do it this
full valid moves
invalid
[Music]
action replayed land land
cool phas attack no valid
attack attack
confirmed
okay we'll see if we get clean logs out
of this right
Block I think we'll get rid of some of
these but
block well
true think we just do this every step
phas turn
action you got rid of the phase thing
right
phas render
label oh this was where our our labels
by
now we have the numbers back on these
cards which is
nice and say we play this and play this
we play this
enter play this
is if I block with this it should be
seven
damage which leaves you with six Health
right six
Health good now I just have to
restructure a little bit
probably will'll have to write a little
AI for this thing as
well
it's like simultaneously printing too
much and not
enough Mana Zone and tapping yeah well
Mana Zone will take a little bit more
time but tapping we should be able
to let me fix a couple things here first
what time is it it's only it's not even
two
what does TCG Trading Card Game
Magic the Gathering Hearthstone Legends
of run Tera one of
those this is the Prototype we're
working with at the
moment uh yeah this looks decent right
now
yeah it's kind of difficult to get a
clean logging with this stuff isn't it
well we can clean up the rendering quite
a bit
okay so you only need this information
when you go to
do contextual here
right who's the attacker and who's the
defender is contextual right
turn one plus and turn
maybe you need to put some systematic
line
braks yeah it's just a little weird
because
um like the same phase gets called
potentially many
times so there's not really a way to not
have the left indent thing
easily
and this should just be board
or hold on this should
be damn
board so this is going to be attacker
board this is Defender
board so let's try like this maybe
yeah so right here this needs to
be
turn goes to one minus
turn and then you go to phase
block and
phase let me see if this does it this
should make it so that we now block our
own
side
[Music]
okay
two two
swing and now we have
this we can swing whoops what did I just
play was that allowed I think that was
valid we swing with
this it rendered something freaking
weird did we not get to block our own
stuff
no they didn't
Health okay well we're not doing damage
somehow
flow trading card game magic the
Gathering D start with decks
yeah well we're trying to get at least a
reasonable prototype here it's very
close to being at least a decent
stack let's figure out why it's not
rendering Health
uh we don't want to do this cuz
like maybe the opponent draws a card at
some point
caught
so pretty easy
right what happened
here attackers one
one can block with
one no no you can't block with one
the defender board has length zero why
the does this get
called do I have this thing backwards
somehow oh yeah yeah yeah I know why
okay it's cuz I switched the way the
turn plays uh the turns play out it's
fine no worries
resolving reducing Health by one oh okay
so it it uh took my health Away by
that's a bad
thing in Star health is going to be
equal
this we're very close here to having
this
Health okay 13 Health
right and then uh we're just going to
pass a little bit here to hope he
attacks me at some
point uh it has rendered text on top of
itself somehow
oh it's just rendered over the card
that's no big
deal still not attacking me
so and then what happens we have an
overflow and draw a
card uh we need to know uh that your
hand is not too big right
bugs play some
[Music]
Land wait for him to attack attack me
with
attack okay so
um whatever the heck that just was
doesn't make any sense because it
has do you see how it has my cards
rendered like this
oh these are the cards that they're
attacking me
with I
are these two just these two are just
backwards
play some
land play this
backwards how's it going hey Spencer
check it out we're almost done with uh
the prototype for the card game so if
you want to jump into
it it's going to be ready very soon
about 600 Lines Just As I
said um I see you've been
great can you play Stones like this on
the edge of the board is this valid
go breakout is base file
yep yep exactly that was the main thing
for
you I'll do a quick a quick code review
on this whenever if it's helpful for
you sorry what do you say about the
stones oh I just haven't played go I
don't can you put stones like this on
the edge of the
board almost done with
this yeah I'll do a quick code review on
this now or whenever you like if it's if
it's helpful to you
pretty sure if it's correct then it's
correct I just don't
know just double check like I said play
a couple games
ago what the heck is wrong with this
attacker
board I had this right before
don't have capture mechanics yeah no
worries it's actually such an easy
environment to do MCTS over if you think
about it as well because like the whole
game state is just so easily represented
as one array without even having to be
fancy so literally you're just you do
MCTS just by like writing that array and
that sets your
why do we need all these lines of
Defenders and why can't we have line for
attackers you just want to draw the way
it works in Magic
is well this is not this is bugged but
the way it works in Magic is you choose
what cards you attack with but then your
opponent chooses uh which cards they're
going to block each of your attackers
with
right so you kind of want to be able to
see like when you're blocking which
cards you're blocking with
what it'll make sense as soon as I have
the rendering
correct because I'll be able to show you
ah so here's the
issue this has got to
see if this does
it on line
attackers no because you get to choose
you get to choose which card your
Defenders
block you see what I
mean like you can choose to block the
first attacker with cards two and three
and then you can block like the third
attacker with card five or
something having now finally watched the
YouTube videos is the point of puffer to
create good environments to massively
test various RL algorithmics algorithms
efficiently new strategy for RL you test
on TCG top one sucks for some other I
mean that's part of it right that's the
current push I mean the goal of puffer
is to fix this cursed
field um and the current thing is is
we've made training fast we've made good
compatible infrastructure for the most
part and the M's are just too slow this
is the current bottleneck so at the
moment it's let's make a bunch of fast
environments right now it's not going to
just be I keep sitting here writing fast
environments for the next five years
until I have a thousand of them right
it's at some point it's going to be okay
we have a bunch of fast environments
maybe people are contributing more of
them but we've got like a decent base
for now uh let's do some methods
research and really figure out why these
methods aren't working as well as they
could be so really the goal of puffer is
to push this field
forward like none of the stuff that
we've been uh building here has existed
before so this is all brand new stuff
block what do you mean my
methods could be algorithms could be
training curricula could be architecture
any stuff right all the other side of
board this seems like it should be
correct so the fact that it's not
correct means
I'm missing something
on oh yeah it's cuz the turn flips
that's
obnoxious it's very obnoxious
I mean I can technically put the indices
on them
attacking and I can add like into
defending
then so we do phaser attack
right
board and we do board cards
attacking equals
not board cards attacking like
this and then we just do board cards
attacking like this
and
then we just do
if uh this actually becomes easier come
to think about it
right because we just
do yeah this actually becomes easier did
you end up using a stack to manage the
different set of yes yes I did so we can
manipulate it down the road yes I did
um the way it works is each of these
things that you see here these functions
they go onto the stack and then they add
stuff to the stack as well so like when
a phase is over it'll just put whatever
the next phase is onto the stack and you
also have control flow execution so what
you can do is you can say whether you
want to put something on the stack and
return control to the user or put
something on the stack but keep going uh
and like keep executing stuff on the
stack so it's very general and it's uh
it's very simple and it took a little
bit more code than I had before but it
should be very easy to work
with this is much much cleaner than I
had
before let me see if I can get this
thing done quickly so we can actually
have the full demo I want this shipped
today so like in the evening maybe I can
chat with you guys and tell you about it
and uh you know what is going to be
needed there
continue just a bit of tricky
refactoring here take me a few minutes
and the board State should not matter
the end of the
Defender
Defenders what's this
here you're already blocking is the goal
here
works and
Defenders yeah know this is
not is there a a flip I think there is
like a
unary
see is there like a cleaner flip wall
not equal true that's interesting I mean
exor but we don't need to do that
I was just trying to see if there was
like a a just like a clean unary
works okay and now we actually we get to
change the uh the rendering here
right so we just get to do if card.
attacking oh that's so nice
attacking and now we don't even have to
do this anymore
attack if attack is negative one then
you
that yeah this is actually way easier
than before
of course I say that knowing that um
there's going to be some stuff to fix
right all right and let's see uh how far
this gets play
land
yeah let's uh fix that
wait I forgot one thing I did forget one
thing
this how is this
possibly defending should be equal to
negative one here that shouldn't be
possible let's see
because I randomized both decks
right say it's zero not negative
oh the lines are just reversed
right yeah it's supposed to be it's
drawing in the wrong direction that's
fine
I'm going to not think about this first
and I'm just going to see if I get if
like my first guess
works that's usually a good strategy
correct there are two things I need to
fix here
fix
that and now the second
thing this should be Defender board
length right
backwards like simply just backwards
right
let me think about this what am I doing
wrong here
wouldn't it just be so much easier if I
did this
separately like what if right
here I guess I have to do it after I
draw the boards
right but
this
huh well this doesn't really do it now
does
so my board
length card y so yeah this is my board
right
hard y
one r.
[Music]
defending here let's just try
this I don't know why I'm being stupid
with this particular thing
but I am going to have to take a break
in a few to get uh a shake because I'm
getting rather hungry
right the opponent board is Row one my
board is row two
right so card X my board length
right board y 30 G2
plus defending opponent
board looks good to me so let's see
what's wrong
here well we still have this Matrix
don't we we have this Matrix to look at
uh this Defender thing is not changing
though when
I when I press this is
the attackers is correct but this
Defenders Matrix looks
right let's figure out how this is
getting computed I don't know if this is
even being
let's see if this fixes the uh crazy
board
stuff so we just do land Z
Z
attack okay board is empty and now we
play a land we play this we do this fine
enter my attacks
here
and what
it really just seems like the uh the
y-coordinate is
flipped doesn't
it yeah it just really seems like the
y-coordinate is flipped so now how the
how was the y-coordinate possibly
two not understanding
this there's something I'm not getting
here
I don't want to just like flip them
because I don't understand
why you
know for
here Def defending with seven it says
right it's a good thing I didn't just
flip it because you can see it's
actually still off
yeah know this index is
wrong well making an rltc GM is awesome
waiting for this overlap mtj and
sometimes Hearthstone player yeah I mean
I uh I asked people if they'd be
interested in this and we got a ton of
people who said they'd be interested in
contributing to this so I'm finishing
the prototype for this in the next
couple of hours here and then this will
just be an open- source project as a
part of puffer so if you're interested
in contributing to stuff on this you
know come on over we need more people on
it
nice great to see you back I I haven't
been able to stream as much lately just
because like I stream Dev right well it
turns out when there's so much Dev uh
there's a point at which it's like no I
just have to grind this out solo you
know
okay
play play a land play
this
six can't play this can play
this takes it a while to pick a random
move we're just going to let it pass a
bit and
then defending
three I am defending three 012 2
uh there's a
rumor no I'm
not I like to be able to go home for
Christmas but what I will do is I will
give these out to anybody I meet up with
we got puffer stickers they're pretty
actually wait does this correct blocking
three with index
two oh
I don't know why this is taking me so
long this really shouldn't be that hard
to
is this is it I have this portion
backwards
there blocking
index with yeah this is it print was
right code below it was
wrong okay we do this we swing Play Our
Land We
swing we play our land we chill a
bit let's play land let's play big
card we wait for them to
swing okay now they
that so watch this I can go like this
and I can just say I'm going to block
you
here and then I can say what's this uh a
one two so I can block you here and then
you both of your cards die
I still took damage to that didn't I
okay so we got to fix some Cals we're so
close at this point
though this is so
this expected
expression I think I have to cast this
right
land
uh now we do our attack or whatever now
we do our land we
play We skip we play land
skip uh land Big
Card wait for them to
swing okay so now we're going to block
you
here and then we're going to block you
here
right what should happen right
is their card should die my first one
should
die my fifth card here let's actually
just like before and after
this just so we can see exactly how this
is messing
okay so what happened is I took two
damage I should not have taken two
the attacker Health wait if the defender
health is less than the attacker's
right you need attacker Health in here
as well and attacker
Health attacker health is going to
be Min equal Defender
attack like this right
and you remove it and you keep
going otherwise you don't kill
it nothing happens I think if you don't
kill it right
no if you don't kill it then your card
is dead
right no that's also not
true ah this is so easy I don't know why
this is bothering
oh it's possible that neither of these
things
if you don't kill
it
and Defender Health doesn't matter
because you don't kill it right
attack is
zero remove is
it Well's play this out again and see if
it makes sense
now land play
cards play our land play
this play our next land pass play land
play Big
Card okay now they swing
now we can block like
this and then we block like this
this okay so they
have block like this
and then we will block this one with our
big card we no longer take damage they
don't take damage
either
and yeah I believe that was good
right and then let's say that we
swing we're going to do big swing
here so this is
up
possibly we'll let him swing
again okay he's going to swing with some
cards uh so what we're going to do is
we're going to intentionally not block
great we're going to
block so we should get one this card
should be killed and we should have one
damage flow through right and then we're
going to block like this I'm going to
take I'm going to take the screenshot
again so we can make sure that this
resolves as we
expect and then we're going to hit
enter and let's see what happened so we
took one
damage as expected we took one damage
right from this card flowing
through we killed their card but this
should not have one right now this
should be this should have been a
reset so why did his
health why did the attacker Health go
wait attack her
health why is this happening
again this is almost done we're
like so good so
close Okay Place some
lands I get some good cards
out let's get like uh
two we wait for them to do
something now we're going to do our
screenshots
again so we're going to perfect block
this and then we're going
to uh we're going to fail here
right see what happened is I took one
damage from failing to block correctly
here we lost both of our cards but he
lost one as
well this is correct let's just do one
more scenario
maybe uh let's get some cards back so we
uh okay so let's just like let him hit
us 17 that's
fine okay perfect this will be a nice
complex scenario so we've got triple
swing here so let's
do we block into this no let's see so I
would probably do block
here and then block here nope a block
this one and then we'll block like
this and
then we'll block
whoops six is already
that was very weird we need to replicate
some stuff I need to at least give them
a working
game yeah that'll be perfect I think I
can get this cleaned up it'll be 4our
stream and then I'll get some other
stuff done in the afternoon after this
solo
okay we play our
lands play
maybe we'd kind of like a three here we
go okay so now we have
this let's
see
okay we're going to get as a side effect
of this we're going to get really fast
at playing Magic the Gathering
play this play
this okay play our
land play
this
okay so this kills both of our cards but
we take no damage right
perfect did he take damage from that I
don't think
so we'll play this and
this and then is two three we're going
to perfect
block like this nobody loses
Health uh do we have five lands we do we
play our big uh we play our c like
this he's got a 2
three we're going to let him hit us 17
damage okay now we have an interesting
thing to
block um so we're going to do block this
with five and this with like this and
then we're going to make sure this will
be our last test case
it's actually kind of interesting that
it should be very easy to make um some
test cases for
so we should take their first card out
which is their two three is gone and we
lose no health for
this and then they take our card out our
34 which they
did uh they keep their
card and we take one damage which is
exactly what happened perfect
and
okay
if r. is
tapped we have is
if color color
equals
AP so it's going to
be uh
28 0 0
red and then
[Music]
here we'll do the same
X
Plus 322
why let's figure out what the heck is up
with
168 32 I don't think that's 80 is it
that's
70 plus 16 no
neither 72
80 but actually this was close enough
oh so it's plus
right
64 let's try
this uh yeah that works but we have to
fix the land
here what if I just do this I'm sure it
won't actually show
up yeah I I don't think this is going to
show
up yeah it just shows up as question
marks on the other screen okay
so we'll just do this at like what
plus
oops just clean up this we're just
cleaning stuff up at the
moment and then the phase
here this phase can go in the bottom of
the screen I think
this is also
not
eight
Phase this is also not symmetrical at
the moment I kind of likeed where the
play button was before to be honest
uh it just needs to
be
symmetrical let me see how this
is get
card so there are four rows of
cards so we
have minus they're 128 each so we've got
to
spare and it's it's four rows so that
means you need
five not divisible by five
80 so what if I just do
be we put the
land we put our card
right we attack with our
[Music]
card now we play our
land look at that it Taps the lands for
us you see that it doesn't turn them yet
but I have it tap like this for
let's see if we can get a cool
screenshot out of this
yeah he just tapped his lands out
okay do I think he's going to
swing let's say I just
hit
nine and then I'm going to do a three
Mana it's like
eight and we
play and he
attacks and then I can do like this
look at
that very
nice just over 600 lines with uh the
extra debug
stuff I think we can get rid of this as
well this is not really useful
best
RB tank
STS
TCG I'm putting it on the web
put in here for now right
oops did I mess this
up yeah I think I
server
poost I need to copy the thumbnail
here and we
can play it
that's pretty good to have this online
already at least early build of
that's did we commit our stuff
here no we
web we modify the setup at
all I don't think so I think this just
builds
working TCG
prototype 100 lines as
promise so the really nice thing about
doing all this in C
it's already online that's all I had to
do no custom code
exactly oops we don't want that we want
the screenshot
they probably have like link detection
stuff for this
but maybe not
I like how easy it is to just get these
things online and playable you
know there's no mouse UI or anything but
you can just do like you know I probably
need to add better instructions to
stuff
um but it
themselves I probably can crash it by
winning to be
fair I haven't really played with the
reset
conditions uh-oh well we'll just let
them
hit
three
two
six
GG oh does it actually reset
I think technically you can just draw a
full hand of lands and just be
cool very
nice I'm gonna hop off for the time
being I'm uh I'm going to get some other
work
done we got a good session in
here and
uh yeah I basically a lot of the dev for
this is just going to be in the Discord
for the next few days um so if you want
to get involved with this project at all
check it out there